anger and turmoil in Guatemala is the
country's anti-corruption prosecutor
continues to try to suspend one of the
two political parties in the
presidential runoff he says it's because
the Samia party that seed in English
illegally registered some members
today before this press conference we
received three more accusations via
phone calls from citizens
to me and its supporters say it's being
targeted by authorities because it wants
to bring change
what's at stake is the rule of law we
can follow Democratic model or fall
directly into authoritarianism
they point to recent history to back up
their claim authorities had already
kicked three candidates from other
parties out the elections before even
the first round of voting including the
front runner unless say they could all
have been thorns in the side of an
economic and political Elite in
Guatemala a deeply unequal Nation
now Samia and their candidate Bernardo
Arevalo formerly long shots at the last
threat standing for now
on Thursday the prosecutor's office even
raided here the offices of the Supreme
electoral tribunal to try and find
records from the Samia party to
strengthen their case that's a highly
unusual move
samiya's a Grassroots movement founded
mainly by academics Bernardo revolo
promises clean governance and an end to
systemic inequality
this is a call for Guatemala's democracy
for clean elections for the possibility
of preventing corrupt groups from
continuing to take over public
institutions
Mayan indigenous leaders we met outside
the Supreme electoral tribunal told us
that's what their communities need
people are tired of so much corruption
with impunity and the lack of
opportunity for our young people because
of that
no one knows if Samir could change that
or if it will get the chance to
John Holman
Guatemala City